American democracy is what we call a
guided democracy in countries that we
don't like like Iran so in Iran
elections are putting aside you know
questions of the credibility of
elections elections are the candidates
are vetted by the leadership the
clerical leadership guardian council
decides who can run ok we're pretty much
the same here candidates are vetted by
corporate interests and unless and the
way it's done is that unless you have
huge corporate financing and support you
just can't run I mean uh
Bhama won over McCain primarily because
the financial institutions liked him
better so poured money into his campaign
much more than McCain and if you check
funding and polls you find that the
advertising and so on in fact carried
him over the edge
and that's true all the way along I mean
the elections are basically bought
Congress for example has very low
ranking among the population you don't
sit in the team sometimes nevertheless
the overwhelming majority of incumbents
win what does that tell you that tells
you people are voting for candidates
that they don't like because they want
any choice that's these are fundamental
defects in the democratic system it's a
huge Democratic deficit as it's gold and
it shows up there's a very sharp
division between public policy and
public attitudes on a host of major
issues in fact both political parties
are well to the right of the population
on a great number of critical issues and
the population feels can't do anything
about it so for example last polls they
saw about this about 80% of the
population I said the government doesn't
work for the people it works for a few
big interests looking out for them
that's 80% of the population but if you
would asked the next question they
didn't do it well what are you gonna do
about it people probably would have said
well I can't do anything there's no way
to do anything about the fact that the
government's in the pockets of the rich
and a few big interests corporate
interests primarily that feeling of
helplessness impotence you know did
everything just run by somebody else I
can't do anything about it that reflects
a democratic deficit these are enormous
problems with the way the Democratic
system functions I mean there's
something similar in most places but the
United States is a pretty extreme in
this regard
among the industrial democracy